[Music]
i mean i know people who have
the stability in the home life and the
families and look at my life and be like
oh my god i wish i had that the fear of
regret is one of the most powerful
tools at your disposal to help you get
into action mode discovering your why is
just the beginning
in order to enjoy all the benefits of
having a clearly articulated why you'll
need to have the courage and discipline
to use it
rise and shine it's espresso time hey
believe nation i am not a morning person
but when you start your day with a
powerful routine that inspires you like
watch one of these videos it will change
your life so let's start your day off
right together grab your coffee know
that i believe in you and get ready for
a shot of espresso from simon sinek
i wake up every morning
is there anything you regret in the last
decade
since you've been building the movement
and momentum for the movement with the
personal life
of course
i mean of course anything you're willing
to share i mean
i mean
of course were there people you were
like wow that could have been a great
relationship or a great friendship or
great yeah you know the the the real the
people that i really connected with my
true friends have stuck with me through
it all you know i i i even now
you know
some people have said sort of as a jab
to me you're too busy to date and the
reality is busy people are patient with
busy people
you know so you know i find that that's
still the case right so
um
look
we make time for the things that matter
to us yeah um and
and
of course i have regrets but but regrets
is not i wouldn't use the word regret of
course there are things that i missed
and but i made a choice and i'm very
happy with that choice and i stand by
that choice because not only have i had
the opportunity the amazing experience
to spread this message and see it
actually grow and be bigger than me but
i'm it's i've i've had the opportunity
to live an absolutely surreal life
because of it my life profoundly changed
course
and i cannot
i can't it's not fair to compare those
things they're not equals
you know you know everybody with
straight hair once curly hair and they
were the curly ones straight hair yeah
once people i mean i know people who
have
the stability in the home life and the
families and look at my life and be like
oh my god i wish i had that and you look
at my life and i'm bouncing all around
and i mean it's the answer is i'm really
grateful
for the life that i live so no regret is
not the word that i would use but there
was a price and a call but there's a
price that it costs that i that i took
willingly yeah the fear of regret is one
of the most powerful
tools at your disposal to help you get
into action mode
let me explain whatever you want to do
whatever your goals are your your
mission your mission your dreams
whatever you want to do
if it's big enough it's going to have
some fear attached to it right you don't
want to just do the same thing over and
over and over and over and over again so
therefore your dreams your ambitions
your drive require you to do things that
are scary that are new that are
different that are pushing you outside
your comfort zone and our natural
reaction is we don't want to do those
things
right in theory we do when we feel bold
and confident we do when you watch a
video like this you get inspired and
motivated like yes i'm going to go do it
and then when it comes time to actually
doing it
you find a reason why you can't do it
right too tired i'll do it tomorrow
there's always some logical reason why
you can't do it meanwhile it's just fear
understand that under underneath your
excuses your reasons are just fear it's
just fear you're afraid of doing the
thing you're afraid of being judged
you're afraid of who will see it you're
afraid of who won't see it you're afraid
of nobody's seeing it you're just afraid
you're afraid
and getting to your dreams require you
to step through that fear
and the future regret
the fear of future regret
is so powerful because it can knock you
out of the immediate fear of doing the
thing
so let me break it down
if you had to
make a video you're gonna make a video
you know i'm making a video right now
right if i was afraid of making this
video i'm afraid to make this video i'm
afraid of i'm gonna have the wrong words
i'm afraid that nina's gonna judge me
for the words that i'm saying
i'm afraid that my dogs are not going to
be happy with me whatever you're afraid
of of what what that guy thinks
for for me with with my phone right
you're you're afraid all these things
come through our our head of what we're
afraid we're afraid of and by the way
nina's very supportive as always we love
you neyman anyway you're afraid so if
you're afraid of making a video great
the fear the present fear is very real
it feels
it feels big right let's call it let's
put it on a fear score the fear of
actually making that video
is a 50 okay it's a score of 50. that's
how much
afraid we are to do it
it's a 50.
the fear of the regret of not doing it
in the moment is not very big maybe it's
a one
right it's just a one it's a one
the the the idea that okay i might
regret this one day whatever it's a one
but the problem is
50 is just for today
that little fear of well it's a big fear
but in the moment of doing the one thing
see it's at 50. it's just today the
regret compounds so it's it's it's one
today it's one tomorrow and it's one the
next day it's one the next day it's one
the next day it actually ends up being a
million right it ends up being huge
the fear of inaction becomes
huge
but we don't feel it on a day-to-day
basis because it's too small compared to
the present fear of doing the thing so
what you have to do
and this is the this is the hack to get
out of procrastination unless you need
it this is the hack to get into action
mode this is the hack too actually start
chasing your dreams don't believe nation
come on let's go
is to make
the fear so big
of regret that you're gonna miss out
that that this video that you're about
to make today is going to be the video
that is life altering life changing life
redefining for you this one thing that
you're about to do
is going to be the greatest moment of
your life
so you make that pain so big
that now it becomes a million
versus the 50
right so then it's not as as scary to go
do the thing
because there's a bigger fear you're
basically inflicting a future pain so
big on you that the present pain doesn't
feel as big
it's when you have a hangnail right when
you have a hangnail
it hurts it's like so annoying you got
this hang nails it's like a stupid
hangout but then if somebody punched you
in the arm
you wouldn't feel the hangnail anymore
because the arm hurts so much
right that's essentially what
you want to do to yourself
it sounds like i'm a masochist but
that's what you want to do to yourself
this little pain that you've got of
making the video making the phone call
doing the action whatever it is it's
like a little hang nail
and what you have to do is punch
yourself in the arm with the fear of all
that future regret
from you not doing it i used to do this
all the time i mean i'm i'm
introverted scared
afraid of a lot of things i'm afraid of
disappointing people it used to really
hold me back it used to really prevent
me from
you know taking the action i need to
take
they used to really hold me back so i
use this constantly
that this thing that i'm about to do is
going to be the thing that sets my
career on fire
this one thing if i don't do it i'm
going to be 120 years old
in my rocking chair
in an old age home
looking back on my life at this moment
today right now
this moment
and wish that i had had more courage
and wish that i had stepped up and wish
that i was more bold
that's what i would tell myself and then
that would give me the strength to go do
the thing and then i'll go do the thing
that makes a big big difference
and so understand that whatever goals
ambitions dreams
that you have for yourself they're
they're noble and they're worthy and
they should be chased down and you're
you're trying to build their build a
better life for yourself and your family
and the people around you and your
purpose comes from your pain and you're
trying to
show all the people who are who are
currently struggling with the thing that
you struggled with that it is possible
that there is hope
achieving your mission is going to
require you to get stronger
and this is the the loop that we
constantly fall back into and that
when the moment comes for you to step up
it's easy to find a way to back down
when the moment comes for you to step up
it's easy to find a way to back down and
the people around you probably aren't
holding you accountable
you're probably already the most
ambitious person that you know
they're looking at you
as inspiration for what's possible as
opposed to saying you should be doing
more
when you say
oh i'm not going to do this today
they're probably giving you a hug or or
you know or even a sea i told you
there aren't many people around us who
push us forward in a loving way to say
no you said you were going to do it go
do it
you're on a mission i'm not letting you
off the hook today you have to go do it
you said you were going to do this thing
this is too important for you to play
small do you have those people in your
life if you do
cherish them hug them hold them keep
them around as much as possible because
you need them and if you don't
you got this
you got me you got espressos you got
this channel you know and you got books
and resources and you know the more
you're around it the more to remind you
to go do it
but the motivation alone isn't enough
it's actually taking the action
and it's scary
and as much as you can talk yourself up
into it
it doesn't matter until you actually go
and do the thing
so use that fear of regret
to get that little boost of courage that
you need to go do the thing that when
you're right up against the wall
you said you were gonna do the thing you
said you're gonna make that video you
said you're gonna make that phone call
and then you're here you're in that
moment you're in that moment you're
about to do it and everything inside you
is saying run
i'm afraid
i can't do this anymore
everything inside you is telling you to
shut off the camera to hang up the phone
to not do that thing right because
you're afraid
you say no
if i do not do this thing
today right now i'm gonna regret it my
entire life
and i'm tired of showing myself
that i say i'm gonna do something and
then i don't show up
i'm tired of showing myself that i'm
saying i'm gonna do something and then i
play small today i change because i
don't want to be 120 years old looking
back on my life wishing that back here
back now right now today
wishing
that i played a bigger game
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
what is your plan of action for the next
week the sign says that when you just
watch a video you get motivated you get
inspired you have a 35 chance of
actually doing something following
through that believe nation is not
enough 35
is not enough we got to do something but
when you get inspired by watching a
video like this and then you create a
plan of action your chances of following
through jump to 91
and when you commit publicly like
putting your comment down below with
your plan it jumps to 95 that's what i
want for you i want you to take action
your dreams are too important your life
matters your mission has to happen so
question of the day your biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week put it down
in the comments below and i'm going to
celebrate alongside with you also if you
want to have more confidence self-love
self-belief check out my 254 series the
sign says it can take up to 254 days of
consecutive action to build a habit so
i've designed a special free program to
help you get it where i will send you an
unlisted video to your email for the
next 254 days to shift your self belief
forward the link to sign up for free is
in the description below we'll walk into
a room and say here's the problem here's
what i think but i'm interested in your
opinion let's go around the room it's
too late i would rather take the risk of
walking out
knowing that i might get moved in a way
that i've never experienced before more
than just going to have a nice night out
and see something that i know is good
successful measurement successful
recognition is not just for the steps
you take it's not just for the effort
it's that the effort you exerted moved
us closer to where we're trying to get
to i did a little experiment with um
um with a homeless person
not like on them it's not like
electrodes
with them voluntarily um helped me
um
because the whole idea of giving right
you've
you've all walked down the street and
you've all seen someone begging and you
either have or haven't
thrown a few pennies in their cup
when you do
you feel good
you bought that feeling
that is a legitimate commercial
transaction you know commercial
transactions are defined as the exchange
of consideration there was an exchange
of consideration here you gave money
you got the feeling of goodwill you paid
for that feeling if you didn't give
money you either feel nothing
or you feel bad
you can't feel good by not giving all
right you paid for that feeling so now
the question is how is that person
encouraging us to give the joke is they
act like every corporation in the world
they talk about themselves
me me me me me me me right
like they sit there with their little
outdoor advertising
little sign
right
and it says i'm homeless i'm hungry i
got 12 kids i'm a veteran god bless they
got it all in there trying to appeal to
somebody the religious vote the veteran
vote you know the child sympathizer
surround yourself with lots of pets go
for that one too
right
all in an attempt to get something from
someone
takers
not givers
right all about me well what do
corporations do
we've added more ram we've added more
rom we've added more speed this one's
number one we're the biggest we're the
best we've been around since 1969 we're
better than them we're faster than them
we're more efficient than that one me me
me me me me me me me
and so even if we buy their product
guess what yeah i won't really feel much
so i did this little experiment i found
um um a nice homeless lady on the
streets of new york was willing to help
out and i learned that with her sign
which was pretty typical i'm homeless
i'm hungry
she makes between 20 and 30 a day
uh for you know for a day's worth of
work eight to ten hours of sitting there
selling goodwill
eight to ten hours she'll make twenty to
thirty dollars thirty dollars is
considered a good day
i changed her sign
and the new sign
made her forty dollars in two hours
and then she left
it's one of the reasons she's homeless
is because she's decided that she only
needs 20 to 30 a day to live if she
stayed she would have made 150
the point is she made 40 bucks in two
hours were the signs say
the sign said
if you only give once a month
please think of me next time
it has nothing to do with the taker it
has everything to do with the giver
and what are the objections people give
when they don't give
i can't give to everyone
how do i know that they really need it
and so i address both those concerns i
know you can't give to everyone so if
you only give once a month my cause is
legitimate i will still be here when
you're ready to give
40 bucks two hours make it about them
not about you
the fact of the matter is 100
of customers
are people
and 100 of clients
are people and 100 of employees are
people i don't care how good your
product is i don't care how good your
marketing is i don't care how good your
design is if you don't understand people
you don't understand business
we are social animals we are human
beings and our survival depends on our
ability to form trusting relationships
do you ever watch um
deadliest catch
on the discovery channel
i was looking through the channels one
night and deadliest catch came on and on
this episode
just random
um
they were in a huge storm
now for those of you who don't know
deadliest catch
they take these crab fishing boats out
in the bering sea which is like
terrible
and they put cameras on them and we
watch
right
the reason that's i guess significant is
because these crab fishermen have i
think one of the top five deadliest jobs
in the world you know i don't know what
the exact number is but dozens of
fishermen die every year
doing doing this
we apparently find that entertaining
which it actually is
so they have cameras only on five or six
of the ships even though there are many
many ships that go out fishing every
season and they don't really come into
proximity with each other because you
know the ocean's huge and they usually
sabotage each other and give each other
false information because they're all
competitors they're all looking to get
the crabs and you know make sure that
they find them somebody else doesn't and
yeah it's business right it's just
business it's okay we all do the same
thing in our own companies
and in this one episode this big huge
storm was so violent that they had to
bring all the pots which are the big
cages that they catch the crabs and
they'd bring all the pots back on the
boat
uh and wait out the storm and just by
dumb luck one of the
boats that had cameras on it
was in proximity of a boat that didn't
have cameras on it and so they filmed
they had secured all their pots on the
deck and so they started filming the
other boat
and they filmed a guy climbing on the
outside of the cage securing
the pots
and all of a sudden a huge wave
hits the side of the boat
and the guy's not there anymore
and the people on the boat with the
cameras start screaming man overboard
man overboard man overboard and they
turn their boat towards
where they think he might be
he's a stranger they don't know him they
don't know the the crew members of the
other boat and yet they react
and they turn towards him
and they find him in the drink and
for those of you who don't understand
how dangerous this is if the water is so
cold that if you're in the water for i
think that it's a minute or a minute 30
hypothermia will set and then you die
and
they come upon him
and he's screaming don't let me die
don't let me die
and they pull him on board not out of
the woods yet they strip off his clothes
because it's wet and cold and they wrap
blankets around him to prevent
hypothermia from setting in
and he survives
and it's overwhelming
and
the captain comes down
and this is all i mean you can go watch
it on tv the camera comes the captain
comes down and he hugs this stranger
this young man his competitor he hugs
this guy as if he's his own son
i
i lost it
everybody is crying
and you realize what happened here was a
human interaction
and the reason they risk their own lives
to help this other person even though
they spend every other day trying to get
ahead in sabotage is because at the end
of the day they're all crab fishermen
and they know something about each other
and they know something about the risk
that they all take
to do this
and when push comes to shove
they will put themselves out there to
help each other for no other reason
than they get it
they're one of the same
i will promise you
that every single member of that crew
that day
went home with a feeling of fulfillment
i promise you that every single person
on that crew that day
felt more good in their hearts and in
their jobs than the richest days that
they've ever pulled in
my question is is what are you doing to
help the person next to you
don't you want to wake up
and go to work
for the only reason that you can do
something good for someone else
wouldn't you want them to do that for
you let me tell you a story
so a friend of mine and i
we went for a run in central park
the roadrunners organization uh on the
weekends they host races
and it's very common at the end of the
race they'll have a sponsor who will
give away something apples or bagels or
something and on this particular day
when we got to the end of the run there
were some free bagels and they had
picnic tables set up and on one side was
a group of volunteers on the table were
boxes of bagels and on the other side
was a long line of runners waiting to
get their free bagel
so i said to my friend let's let's get a
bagel and he looked at me and said
ah the line's too long
and i said
free bagel
and he said i don't want to wait
in line
and i was like
free bagel
and he says nah let's it's too long
and that's when i realized that there's
two ways to see the world
some people see the thing that they want
and some people see the thing that
prevents them from getting the thing
that they want
i could only see the bagels
he could only see the line
and so
i walked up to the line
i
leaned in between two people
put my hand in the box and pulled out
two bagels
and no one got mad at me
because the rule is you can go after
whatever you want you just cannot deny
anyone else to go after whatever they
want now i had to sacrifice choice i
didn't get to choose which bagel i got i
got whatever i pulled out but i didn't
have to wait in line
so the point is is you don't have to
wait in line you don't have to do it the
way everybody else has done it
you can do it your way
you can break the rules you just can't
get in the way of somebody else getting
what they want that's rule number one
rule number two
i like this one
in the
18th century
there was something that
spread across europe and eventually made
its way to america puerto fever
also known as the black death of child
bed
basically what was happening
is women were giving birth
and they would die within 48 hours after
giving birth
this black death of childbirth
was the ravage of europe and it got
worse and worse and worse over the
course of over a century
in some hospitals
it was as high as 70 percent of women
who gave birth who would die as a result
of giving birth
but this was the renaissance
this was the time of empirical data and
science and we had thrown away things
like tradition and mysticism these were
men of science these were doctors
and these doctors and men of science
wanted to study and try and find the
reason
for this black death of
child bed and so they got to work
studying and they would study the
corpses
of the
of the women who had died and in the
morning they would conduct autopsies
and then in the afternoon they would go
and deliver babies and finish their
rounds
and it wasn't until somewhere in the
mid-1800s
that dr oliver wendell holmes father of
supreme court justice oliver wendell
holmes realized
that all of these doctors were
conducting autopsies in the morning
weren't washing their hands before they
delivered babies in the afternoon
and he pointed it out and said guys
you're the problem
and they ignored him and called him
crazy
for 30 years
until finally somebody realized that if
they simply washed their hands
it would go away
and that's exactly what happened when
they started sterilizing their
instruments and washing their hands the
black death of childbed
disappeared
my point is the lesson here is
sometimes you're the problem
we've seen this happen all too recently
with our new men of science and
empirical uh studiers and
these men of
finance
who are smarter than the rest of us
until the thing collapsed
and they blamed everything else except
themselves
and my point is is take accountability
for your actions you can take all the
credit in the world for the things that
you do right as long as you also take
responsibility for the things you do
wrong it must be a balanced equation you
don't get it one way and not the other
you get to take credit
when you also take accountability nelson
mandela is a particularly special case
study in the leadership world because he
is universally regarded as a great
leader
you can take other personalities and
depending on the nation you go to we
have different opinions about other
personalities but nelson mandela across
the world is universally regarded as a
great leader
he was actually the son of a tribal
chief
and he was asked one day
how did you learn to be a great leader
and he responded that he would go with
his father
to tribal meetings
and he remembers two things when his
father would meet with other elders
one
they would always sit in a circle
and two
his father
was always the last to speak
you will be told your whole life that
you need to learn to listen i would say
that you need to learn to be the last to
speak i see it in boardrooms every day
of the week even people who consider
themselves good leaders who may actually
be decent leaders will walk into a room
and say here's the problem here's what i
think but i'm interested in your opinion
let's go around the room it's too late
the skill to hold your opinions to
yourself until everyone has spoken does
two things one it gives everybody else
the feeling that they have been heard
it gives everyone else the ability to
feel that they have contributed
and two you get the benefit of hearing
what everybody else has to think before
you render your opinion
the skill is really to keep your
opinions to yourself if you agree with
somebody don't nod yes
if you disagree with somebody don't not
know
simply sit there take it all in and the
only thing you're allowed to do is ask
questions so that you can understand
what they mean and why they have the
opinion that they have you must
understand from where they are speaking
why they have the opinion they have not
just what they are saying
and at the end
you will get your turn
it sounds easy it's not
practice being the last to speak
that's what nelson mandela did success
is an elusive thing right um
what is it
and i think it's very interesting that
if most people can't define success well
it means you made x amount of dollars or
but if you make x amount of dollars but
you spend more are you successful or
well it means you come home happy every
day okay how do you know when you're
happy you know
so
i think success is a funny thing which
is we all seem to pursue it but we don't
know how to measure it or actually how
to define it
so how do you pursue something that you
can't measure fascinating
um so
when people say to me how do you measure
success the question we all have to ask
ourselves am i successful
i don't know i mean i had a good year
last year uh
and what does that mean does that mean i
made a lot of money does that mean i was
really happy oh i'll let you decide
right right maybe neither maybe both
um
i had a good year last year but am i
successful and the answer is no i don't
feel i am because i'm trying to build a
world that doesn't exist yet i'm trying
to build a world in which 90 of people
go home at the end of the day feeling
fulfilled by the work that they do so i
definitely took a step a big step
forward towards that goal but i'm still
so far away so somebody said to me then
how do you know if you're successful and
the answer is
if it can go by itself and so what is
more interesting to me as a measurement
of success is not the the the markers
per se it's not the the financial goal
or the
the size of the house that you want to
buy those are nice things go for it
those are but those are not measurements
of success those are just nice things to
collect along the way right
for me it's momentum i want to measure
momentum which is you know when when
something is moving and you start to see
it lose momentum you're like oh
give it a push because if you don't give
it push it's going to stop and an object
in stasis is much harder to get going it
requires a lot more energy to get
something started than it does to keep
it going right and so if you don't let
it stop and you can keep it going it's
this you know it still might slow down
down there but you can get it going
again much easier and for me the
opportunity is to get the ball rolling
faster and faster and faster and faster
and faster and bigger and bigger and
bigger it's like a snowball and my
responsibility is because it's not
rolling downhill yet it's not on
automatic yet i need to still keep it
going to find that critical mass where
it can go
and at the point it can go by itself
without me then i will find something
else to do and that may not happen in my
lifetime i think we must all stop
measuring promotions salaries and these
things but rather measure the momentum
of your career does my career have
momentum can i see it moving in the
right direction can i see it gathering
moss you know uh can i see that it's
easy becoming easier for me to keep the
momentum it's becoming easier for me to
grow the size of this thing it's it's
requiring less effort that's the thing
we need to measure that's the thing that
we need to be cognizant of which is the
momentum of our careers not just the
markers that we think define our success
every decision we make in our lives is a
piece of communication
every decision we make in our lives as
individuals or as organizations
is a piece of communication it's our way
of saying something about who we are and
what we believe this is why authenticity
matters
this is why you have to say and do the
things you actually believe because the
things you say and do are symbols of who
you are
and we look for those symbols so we can
find people who believe what we believe
our very survival depends on it so if
you're putting out false symbols you
will attract people to those symbols but
you won't be able to form trust with
them this is what tiger woods did to us
he lied
he lied he told us what he thought we
wanted to hear
and it was great and we were drawn to it
and all of us who kind of liked that
idea of the sort of the good guy we're
drawn to it until we found out it was a
lie
he could have been the bad boy of golf
he could have had all the same
endorsements and had a fantastic career
and still been hailed as one of the
great
athletes of our day
but he didn't he chose to lie
good luck forming trust again tiger we
don't believe you
we don't trust you
the goal of putting something out there
if you say what you believe and you do
what you believe you will attract people
who believe what you believe
if you go to one of your friends and you
say to one of your friends
how would you like me to dress
so that you'll like me better
how would you want me to address you how
do you want me to speak
so that you'll like me more
right your friends are going to look at
you be like
what are you talking about
come on come on come on what should i
wear so that you'll find me more
appealing and how would you like me to
speak to you so that you like me more
and your friends are going to tell you
just be yourself
that's why i like you i don't just be
yourself now think about what we do in
industry what do we do we do market
research and we go and we ask the
customers what kind of things the way we
what style should we speak to you how
should we decorate ourselves what kind
of things are you drawn to so that we
can do those things so you'll like us
more it's just as ridiculous
it's just as ridiculous organizations
should say and do the things they
actually believe and they will attract
people who believe what they believe or
they can choose to lie and at the
slightest hint
that they might be lying cynicism sets
in and people start saying i'm not sure
i can trust these guys because there's
not a lot of consistency in all the
things they say and do which means they
can't have a very strong belief set or
they're lying to me
and we call them inauthentic the entire
process of asking other people who we
should be is inauthentic that's
hilarious to me all these positioning
studies we do are inherent we're going
to do a study to find out from people so
we can be more authentic that's
hilarious
say and do what you actually believe and
the symbols you put out there the things
you're saying the things you do those
red hats are ways that people can find
you what you have the ability to do
as designers is create those symbols
and allow people to use those things to
say something about who they are work
for companies work for clients work for
people who you believe what they believe
show up and feel a part of something
bigger than yourself
and your part
is to put what they believe into
pictures and words and symbols and
graphics so that other people can use
those things to say something about who
they are
people put harley davidson logos on
their body to say something about who
they are corporate logo
ain't no procter and gambles tattooed on
anybody's arm
because harley means something they
stand for something people put that
tattoo on there not to tell you that
they own a motorcycle they put that
tattoo there to tell you something about
themselves
you ever see anybody with a with a mac
laptop with a sticker over that
beautiful shining apple ain't never
gonna happen
then how will you know who i am
do you ever see anybody with a pc break
out the windex to clean out their
computer
mac people
have you ever seen a dirty mac
doesn't exist
does not exist why because it's who i am
these are symbols we use the companies
that are crystal clear in what they
believe
and they're disciplined in how they do
it they're consistent in what they do
and everything they say and everything
they do serves as a symbol of the set of
values and beliefs we use those symbols
to say something about who we are
we surround ourselves with the people
and the products and the brands that say
something about who we are
and when we can find the people who
believe what we believe we're weirdly
drawn to them
because our very survival
depends on it
we need it and so the more you can give
of yourself the more you can give of
what you believe the more you can
discipline with discipline say in blue
and do the things you actually believe
strange things start to happen dopamine
is the feeling
uh that you've found something you're
looking for or do you accomplish
something you set out to accomplish
so you know that feeling you get when
you cross something off your to-do list
that's dopamine feels awesome you know
when you when you have a goal to hit and
you achieve that goal you're like yes
you feel like you've won something right
that's dopamine the whole purpose of
dopamine is to make sure that we get
stuff done
right
um
the historical reason for dopamine we
would never eat
if we only waited to get until we got
hungry because there's no guarantee that
we would find food so dopamine exists to
help us go looking for food we get
dopamine when we eat which is one of the
reasons we like eating and so when you
see something that reminds you of
something that feels good we want to do
the behavior that helps us get that
feeling right so let's say you're out
there going for a walk and you see an
apple tree in the distance
you get a small hit of dopamine and then
what it does is it focuses us on our
goals and now we start walking towards
the apple tree and as the apple tree
starts to get a little bigger we feel
like we're making progress you get
another little shot of dopamine and
another little shot of dopamine until
you get to the tree and you're like yes
okay this is why we're told you must
write down your goals your goals must be
tangible there's a there's a biological
reason for that we we're very very
visually oriented animals you have to be
able to see the goal
for it to biologically stay focused
right if you don't write down your goals
if you can't see your goals it's very
hard to get motivated to get inspired
for example think about corporate
visions right a corporate vision is have
to be something we can see right that's
why it's called a vision
you can see it
right to be the biggest most respected
to be the fastest growing are not
visions they're nothing
right
what does that even look like respected
by whom your mother yourself your
friends your shareholders who knows
what's the metric done oh it's amorphous
doesn't motivate us
just like i can't tell you you will get
a bonus if you achieve more
you're going to ask me how much more
i'm going to say
more
doesn't work you need a tangible goal
you need a tangible goal right here's a
great vision martin luther king i have a
dream
that one day
little black children and little white
children will play on the playground
together and hold hands together we can
imagine that we can set our sights on
that and every time we achieve a goal
and achieve a metric and achieve a
milestone that makes us feel like we're
making progress to the
vision we can see we keep going and
going and going until we achieve
something remarkable
you have to be able to see it dopamine
like i said dopamine is the feeling you
get
when you set out to find something
you're looking for as well
talked about the to-do list i came home
from
a trip just a couple days ago and i had
a bunch of errands to run and i wrote
down a little list of things i had to do
and off i went right
and as i was walking past i think it was
a drag queen i don't remember i was
walking past something i remembered oh i
have to do that and i hadn't written it
down on my i had written down on my
to-do list so i went in and finished
what i needed to do and then when i came
out i then wrote it on my to-do list and
then crossed it out
because i wanted the dopamine feels good
dopamine comes with a warning
dopamine is highly
highly
highly
addictive
here are some other things that release
dopamine
alcohol
nicotine
gambling
your cell phone
oh you think i'm joking
okay we've all been told that uh you
know uh
if you wake up in the morning
and you crave a drink you might be an
alcoholic well if you wake up in the
morning the first thing you do is check
your phone before you even get out of
bed
you might be an addict
if you walk from room to room in your
own apartment holding your telephone
you might be an addict
when you're driving in your car and you
get a text and your phone goes beep
we we hate email true we love the beep
the buzz the ding oh
right
you'll be there in 10 minutes and yet
you have to look at it right now
you might be an addict and even if you
read it and it says are you free for
dinner next thursday and you have to
reply immediately you can't wait to 10
minutes
you might be an addict
and for all you gen y's out there who
like to think that you're better at
multitasking but you grew up with the
technology then why do you keep crashing
your cars when you're texting
you're not you're not better at
multitasking you're better at getting
distracted
in fact if you look at the statistics
add adhd have
diagnosis of add and adhd have risen 66
in the past 10 years
okay add adhd is a frontal lobe disorder
right are you telling me out of nowhere
66 of our youth has a frontal lobe
problem where did that come from no it's
a misdiagnosis right what what are the
what are the symptoms of a dopamine
addiction to technology distractibility
inability to uh to get things done
easily easily distracted you know
shortness of attention it's all the same
thing so we misdiagnose things it's this
it's the addictive quality of dopamine
we can also get addicted to performance
in our companies when all they do is
give us numbers to hit numbers to hit
numbers to hit and a bonus you get and a
bonus you get and a bonus you get all
they're doing is feeding us with
dopamine and we can't help ourselves all
we do is want more more more it's no
surprise that the banks destroyed the
economy because one of the things we
know about dopamine addict is they will
do anything to get another hit sometimes
at the sacrifice of their own resources
and their relationships ask any
alcoholic gambling addict or or drug
addict
ask them how their relationships are
doing and if they've squandered any of
their resources it's an addiction
dopamine is dangerous
if it is unbalanced it is hugely helpful
when in a comfortable and balanced
system but when unbalanced
it's dangerous and it's destructive you
speak to businesses and companies and
leadership teams and employees and stuff
without mentioning names i don't want to
put you on the spot but have you gone
and talked to a company that's been in
trouble
and then spoken to their team
and then checked in on them after you've
spoken to their leadership team and what
did that look like did you notice a
noticeable change did they come to you
and tell you that this has helped our
organization out and our culture is much
improved because of it
you mean does my work
i mean
sure
here's the problem with my stuff
you got to do it
and i
am not i'm not anybody's like
you know
mom or dad i'm not going to do it for
you and i have a very less fair approach
of it i once had a i once had a client
this is
a bunch of years ago that said what
guarantee do i have that your stuff will
work
to which my answer was none
like
i i'm giving you a tool
you can it's like a hammer you can use
it broadly or narrowly you can build a
table you can build a house it's the
same tool you can use it for marketing
you can use it to completely revitalize
your entire culture and even though i'm
going to sell you the most beautiful
hammer i'm not going to guarantee the
structural integrity of the house
right it's your business you want to
ignore all my stuff ignore it i don't
care it's your and if your business
collapses you know what happens to me
nothing
like i don't mean to be cold about it
like of course i want the people i work
with to do well but it's not mine it's
theirs and i take no emotional
responsibility for the decisions they
make so yes there are many people that
i've had the pleasure of working with
some who worked for dysfunctional
organizations that went on the hard
journey of completely changing the way
they lead and completely revitalizing
their culture and it has great success
it's not because of me it's because of
them
right at the same time there are many
people who came in like what an amazing
speech and did nothing
you know thanks that was great you know
and i don't it's of course it's going to
fail
you know so i
i think that we have too much
especially in the consulting world or
the design world everybody's so
paternalistic
about it and designers are famous for
this right they get so personally
offended when the client chooses the
wrong thing
oh there's such videos don't they know
we're trying to help them
or who cares
like it's their freaking business
that's what you find i've i've had that
instead of arguing with somebody for
them the right choice which because we
genuinely want to help them what i have
found is if you push the accountability
down to because when we argue we're
taking accountability this is better
this will help you
we're taking responsibility
accountability but if we say look
we've been doing this a bunch of years
we know more about design than you do
um
i'm telling you for every reason that i
can outline for you why this will help
you more
but if you don't want to do it that's
fine it's your business do what you want
the minute you switch the accountability
and put it all on them amazingly they're
much more open to your opinion
because now they're responsible imagine
we're standing
in a big empty room right
and we're standing in one corner and i
give you a simple instruction
i want you to go to that corner in a
straight line
right off you go no big deal right
without telling you i slip a chair in
front of you what do you do
you go around the chair
now you just disobeyed what i told you
to do i told you to go to that corner
straight line but this is the amazing
things about human beings which is when
we're given a clear destination
we use our own creativity and our own
sense of innovation and our own
problem-solving abilities to overcome
obstacles to get to the destination in
other words the destination is more
important than the route
right we're flexible about the route
we're obsessed with the destination
reset we're standing in the corner
together and i give you a simple
instruction
go somewhere in this room in a straight
line
and you say to me where do you want me
to go i'm like i don't know you're smart
figure it out go in a straight line and
so you pick a point and you start
walking and without telling you i put a
chair in front of you and what do you do
you come to a grinding halt and i say
what did you stop for you go will you
put a chair in front of me
or you'll make a sudden turn and go in
another direction
right and this is the problem it's the
same obstacle
the difference is when you have a clear
set at a clear destination the obstacles
become easy to overcome when you don't
have a clear destination you keep coming
to a grinding hold and what we do in our
companies is we're counting the steps
we're taking along the route but we're
never looking at the destination right
so company says
made a million dollars this year we were
only planning on making eight hundred
thousand we took ten steps we're only
planning on taking eight
where are you going no clue right
we count the steps and so the point is
is that people want to feel that the
effort that they're exerting actually
are moving somewhere and so successful
measurement successful recognition is
not just for the steps you take it's not
just for the effort it's that the effort
you exerted moved us closer to where
we're trying to get to and that get to
should be some crazy ideal my ideal is
to live in a world in which the vast
majority of people wake up every single
morning you know inspired to go to work
and fulfilled by the work that they do
and the the couple of measurements that
i use are if the book is selling and i
by the way people ask me how many have
you sold i have no clue i've never asked
the publisher because i don't care i
really don't care how many i've sold
what i care about is the amazon rankings
and that those are going steady or up
and not plummeting because that means
other people right because i don't have
a publicist i don't have a marketing
strategy on purpose i didn't hire one of
those companies to sell the book for me
and the reason is is because i'm not
interested in book sales i'm interested
in spreading an idea and so i just use
that as a metric to help me understand
am i sort of marching in the because the
more i preach is it resonating
you know and so you have a couple of
these imperfect measurements that help
you understand are you going along the
way so it's not just great effort look
what you achieved because that's what
we're doing now
right our goal is to increase top line
revenues by 50 million dollars
for what reason
right which is we have to know the
destination and then
we say
amazing you took us that much closer and
if we go to the right it's because we
were overcoming an obstacle
if we hadn't gone to the right we would
have been stuck forever thank you you
know it's not always straight lines it's
not always straight lines but it's it's
in one direction she's pulling the cane
out discovering your why is just the
beginning
in order to enjoy all the benefits of
having a clearly articulated why you'll
need to have the courage and discipline
to use it like thomas edison said vision
with that execution is hallucination
there is an ideal order for implementing
your why though sometimes reality does
get in the way and it all starts with
you
our natural tendency is to start with
the tangible we define our value by what
we do so it takes practice to start with
why
like riding a bicycle at first we're
unsure unsteady we're in our heads
thinking about all the things we need to
do pedal fast keep enough speed so we
don't fall over
we have to really concentrate we may
even fall over even scrape our knees but
we get back on the bike and try again
and eventually it becomes natural
starting with y is no different at first
it feels awkward it may not even work
but with practice it will become so
natural that you won't even be able to
imagine a time when you couldn't do it
just like riding a bicycle
in time your why will act as a filter
for many of the decisions and choices
you make it becomes a tool to help you
find a job or seize an opportunity in
which you're more likely to succeed
it removes a lot of the guessing
here's a metaphor to show you what i
mean it's called the celery test
we're constantly asking people for their
advice on what to do or how to do it
it's like going to a dinner party and
somebody says do you know what you need
you need m ms we've done so well with m
m's you've got to use m ms somebody else
says to us rice milk in this economy you
have to use rice milk
someone else says to us kit kats you
have to use kitkats and somebody else
says to you it's all about salary we go
to the supermarket with all this good
advice from all these smart people with
brilliant case studies and we buy
everything we buy kit kats and m ms
celery and rice milk there's a lot of
time we spend at the supermarket and a
lot of money we spend at the supermarket
and when we get to the checkout lane
we're standing there with all these
products in our hands and no one can see
what we believe because we bought
everything
but let's imagine we know our why let's
imagine our why is to always be healthy
and only do things that protect the
health of our bodies
now which products do we buy given all
the same advice from all the same smart
people this time we only buy celery and
we only buy rice milk they're the only
two that makes sense
we spend less time and less money at the
supermarket and when we're standing
there in line with only celery and only
rice milk now people can see what we
believe
somebody walking past can say hey i can
see that you're healthy so am i
you just attracted an opportunity or a
referral or a friend simply by saying
and doing the things that you believe
and the best part is it's scalable as
soon as i said the why you knew exactly
which products we were going to buy
this means the more you can articulate
your why the more others will know what
you stand for and will be able to help
you make the right decisions from now on
you will work to ensure everything you
do is a good fit
if you do too many things that aren't a
good fit you'll feel uncomfortable and
people will feel that you're being
inauthentic
on the other hand when you start with
why
your ability to stand out find support
and work to all your natural strengths
will flourish with practice you will
learn to trust your why you will
eventually start to see your job and the
things you do as ways to breathe life
into your cause
and the better you get at it the more
you will feel that your life and
everything you do has purpose
the best way to implement your why is to
work at it slowly you don't have to do
all the tips we suggest what is
important is that you pick up to three
and commit to practicing and using them
now so i'll tell you another story
it's a personal story it's not one that
i share very often
and it profoundly changed
the course of my life
in august of 2011
i had the opportunity to visit
afghanistan with the united states air
force
i had done some work with the mobility
forces these the people that fly the
tankers and the cargo planes and air
force one all the big planes
and the general said to me simon you've
gotten to know us quite well
it would mean a lot to me
if you would go
to either iraq or afghanistan
to see our men and women perform their
mission
would you be willing to go
so i said yes
they picked afghanistan
now i didn't tell my parents where i was
going because i didn't want them to
worry
i told them i was going away with the
air force true
i told them i was going to be out of
touch for a while because i was going to
be on a lot of planes
true
i told them i was going to germany
true
i just didn't tell them from germany i
was going to afghanistan
and i had no responsibility i was simply
going as an observer
i had two officers who were assigned to
be my escorts and we met basically for
the first time at penn station in
philadelphia where we drove to dover air
force base where we would leave for
germany we took a big c5 cargo plane
in germany we changed planes and we got
on a kc-135 tanker
built in 1956.
i was on a plane built in 1956
where we flew to bagram
we landed in the middle of the night
we touched down
and the big door in the side of the
plane had opened but we hadn't gotten
off the plane yet we'd been on the we'd
been on the ground for maybe 10 minutes
and the base came under rocket attack
three rockets hit a hundred yards off
our nose this is how my trip began
now if you've ever been in a war zone
for those of you in the room who've ever
been in a war zone you have you know
this you have all the feelings you're
supposed to have you just don't have
them at the right times
weirdly i was incredibly relaxed and
maybe that's because the people i was
with were incredibly relaxed and i felt
safe
we were event the panic came later
we're eventually given the all clear and
we went to our housing
now the purpose of being in afghanistan
we're going to be in the country for up
to 30 hours and the goal was to
witness an airdrop mission
they're not regularly scheduled so we
had to find out if there was one as soon
as we got there and it turns out there
was one first thing in the morning
so we got about two and a half hours
three hours of sleep and we went and got
on this air drop mission which was
incredible we sat in the back of a c-17
we flew about an hour and a half two
hours out to the middle of nowhere
afghanistan the plane dropped down to
about 2000 feet the back door opened and
we sat there and watched
as cargo flew out the back so we could
resupply an army forward operating base
it was an amazing amazing experience
we then flew back to bagram and the goal
was to come back home
there's no regularly scheduled flight so
we have to sort of find out what flights
we can get on and it's always up to the
discretion of the pilots we found a
flight that was leaving
shortly after we got back and so we
asked the pilots and they said
absolutely we can join their flight and
we waited and waited and waited and
waited and waited and waited and
eventually we got on the plane we were
all strapped in literally five minutes
from leaving and the pilot walked up to
us and said i'm sorry we need to bump
you guys we need to make more room for
stretchers it was carrying wounded
warriors out of out of theater and they
needed our space if there's ever a good
reason to get bumped off a plane this
was it so we got off the plane and we
went to look for another flight
and that's when we found out
there were no other flights until
tuesday and this was only saturday
i was gonna get stuck in afghanistan for
at least four days maybe longer because
we don't know what we're gonna get on on
tuesday and i have no way of telling my
parents
they're not gonna hear from me on the
date that i told them that i would get
home
immediately every fiber of my being sank
and i remember becoming completely
panicked
and completely preoccupied with one
thing
my happiness my safety and my comfort
and i didn't care who had to go out of
their way to get me what i wanted
i remember there was a public affairs
officer who said i can get you to
kyrgyzstan but you don't have the right
visa and i looked at him and i said you
get me on that plane i don't talk to
people like that and i could see myself
becoming this person that i hated
some of us in the room have worked for
somebody in our careers who
wants the next promotion and they don't
care that they have to tie our turn our
lives upside down so they can get what
they want i was becoming that person
we went back to our housing
and i lay down on the bed and closed my
eyes
my mind was racing i was convinced that
there would be another rocket attack on
the base i was convinced that i was
going to get hit i was convinced that my
parents were going to find out that i
was in afghanistan when an arm an air
force officer knocks on the door i was
convinced paranoia fear everything that
you can imagine swept over me
one of the officers that i was traveling
with said i'm gonna see if i can get us
on another flight and he left the room
the other officer thinking i was asleep
just because my eyes were closed said
well i'm gonna go to the gym then and he
walked out and turned off the lights for
me
i couldn't sleep my mind was racing all
i wanted to do was get out of there i
regretted saying yes i regretted being
there i didn't want to be there
i'm in the purpose business i write and
talk about this sense of why and sense
of purpose in our lives so i started to
remind myself simon you need a purpose
you don't have a purpose you need a
purpose so i started inventing one
you're here to tell their story
it worked for like a few minutes and it
would slide back into my fear and panic
again
and i realized what was happening to me
is i was living the equivalent of an
unfulfilled life
compressed into 24 hours
i had an amazing day i got to see
something that most people will never
get to see in their entire lives except
i didn't want to wake up and do it again
the next day
and i think many of us do the same thing
we can we confuse moments of happiness
with joy and fulfillment
we confuse winning a piece of business
getting a promotion getting an award
getting recognition doing well on a test
with actual deep fulfillment
those experiences are wonderful but
happiness is fleeting
there's not a single person in this room
absolutely zero who's walking around
with an amazing sense of accomplishment
for that test that you aced a year ago
that feeling
is gone
fulfillment is something entirely
different
it's something you carry with you on a
daily basis whether you're enjoying the
day or not
it's like loving your family you may not
like your family every day but you love
your family every day
one is fleeting the other is lasting
and this is what was happening to me i
realized that i had this amazing day and
i was confusing
happiness and fulfillment
and so i gave up i lay in that bed
paranoid scared and depressed and i
literally
gave up
i decided that if i was going to get
stuck here
i might as well make myself useful
and so i decided i was going to
volunteer i would speak anywhere they
wanted me to speak
i would carry boxes and sweep floors all
i wanted to do was serve some of those
amazing people that i'd met on this trip
i wanted to serve those who served
others
and instantly this incredible calm came
over me
i was even
excited
this is what fulfillment means
it's not the fleeting joys that we may
experience it's not the accomplishments
that we achieve
it's the opportunity to serve those who
serve others
and upon making this realization i had
nothing but joy and calm and excitement
and peace
it was like a movie the timing was
uncanny upon making this amazing
realization the door flung open
and it was major throk morton he said i
got us on a flight that's been a flight
that's been redirected but we have to go
now we have to go now if we don't leave
now they're going to leave without us
where's matt i said he's at the gym
so we ran to the gym we got him off the
treadmill we ran back no time to shower
he put his uniform back on we grabbed
all our stuff and we ran out to the
flight line
when we got out to the flight line we
could see the plane we were going to go
we were going to take home
see big c-17 it was sitting right out
there on the tarmac and as soon as we
got there a security cordon came down
and they wouldn't let us out to the
plane
because somewhere else on base
they were having a fallen soldier
ceremony and out of respect when they
have the fallen soldiers ceremony
everything stops
and so so we we sat on the curb and
waited
and i told the guys what i had gone
through
in the bed just moments ago
and i cried like a baby
and this is one of the things a lot of
people don't realize about the military
crying is just fine
those guys kept me safe not just
physically they made me feel safe
and i felt totally comfortable telling
them what i was going through and how i
felt
eventually the security cordon came up
and they let us out to the plane we
would be the only three passengers
aboard this plane other than the crew
what i didn't tell you
is the reason the flight was redirected
is because we would be carrying home the
fallen soldier for whom they just had
the ceremony
the army
brought the flag drape casket on board
all the air force crew stood in the line
at perfect attention i'm a civilian i
put my hand on my heart i felt kind of
stupid so i stood at attention with the
air force
crew as the army laid the casket in the
middle of the aircraft they hold it a
very slow eight-count salute
they marched off the plane
and we watched them hugging and crying
as they walked away
the crew got to work strapping this
precious cargo down
we then had a nine and a half hour
overnight flight back to germany
where i slept right next to this casket
on every other plane i went on we talked
we joked barely a word was spoken in
nearly 10 hours on every other flight i
visited the cockpit and hung out with
the crew i didn't visit the cockpit once
and i'll tell you it was one of the
greatest honors of my life
having just gone through this incredibly
strange experience on the ground
i had the honor of bringing home
somebody who understands service much
deeper than i will ever understand it
serve those who serve others
and you will live a life of joy
and fulfillment if you want more
inspiration morning videos they're not
on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it it's right
there next to me go click it there
continue to believe and i'll see you
there